>>> NEW REPORTING FROM "THE
WASHINGTON POST" THAT FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS STRUGGLING TO
ASSEMBLE A TEAM OF VETERAN
LAWYERS TO DEFEND HIM AGAINST
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
INVESTIGATION INTO THE HANDLING
OF CONFIDENTIAL DOCUMENTS AT
MAR-A-LAGO.
JOINING US, NATIONAL POLITICAL
REPORTER AT "THE WASHINGTON
POST" ISAAC ARMSDORF, PART OF
THE TEAM THAT BROKE THE STORY.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
WHAT ARE YOU REPORTING THIS
MORNING IN TERMS OF THE SEARCH
FOR LAWYERS?
>> SO THERE IS DEFINITELY A
RECOGNITION AMONG SOME OF
TRUMP'S ADVISERS THAT THEY NEED
SOME MORE LEGAL FIREPOWER HERE,
THAT THIS IS A VERY SERIOUS AND
COMPLICATED CASE, HAS A LOT OF
LEGAL ISSUES, UP AGAINST THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WITH ALL
ITS RESOURCES, AND THEY NEED
SOME HEAVY HITTERS.
THEY NEED SOME PEOPLE WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCE WORKING AND WINNING
CASES AT THIS LEVEL.
AND THAT'S -- THE PROBLEM IS
THEY HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN GOING
AROUND TRYING TO ADD THOSE
PEOPLE TO THE TEAM, AND THEY
HAVE BEEN HEARING A LOT OF NOs.
>> SO THEY DO HAVE TWO LAWYERS
WITH EXPERIENCE.
THEY HAVE EVAN CORCORAN,
BANNON'S LAWYER AND JIM TRUSTY,
SOMEONE WITH FEDERAL EXPERIENCE
HERE.
WHY DO THEY NEED MORE?
AND WHY ARE PEOPLE SAYING NO?
>> THEY ALSO HAVE JOHN RALLY WHO
HAS BEEN HANDLING SOME OF THE
INTERACTIONS WITH THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND HE ALSO HAS SOME
EXPERIENCE.
BUT THEN, YOU KNOW, LOOKING AT
THE REST OF THE TEAM YOU'VE GOT
A FORMER OAN HOST, YOU'VE GOT A
PROPERTY INSURANCE LAWYER WHO
JOINED THE BAR IN 2014, AND
YOU'VE GOT SOMEONE WHO LEADS A
THREE-PERSON FIRM AND USED TO BE
THE GENERAL COUNSEL FOR A
PARKING GARAGE COMPANY.
SO ONE ISSUE IS THE LEVEL OF
EXPERIENCE AND ALSO THE
LEADERSHIP.
WHO IS IN CHARGE HERE?
WHO IS GOING TO RUN THIS?
AND ORDINARILY REPRESENTING THE
FORMER PRESIDENT IN A HIGH
PROFILE CASE LIKE THIS WOULD BE
THE OPPORTUNITY OF A LIFETIME,
THAT ALL SORTS OF FAMOUS LAWYERS
WOULD BE CLAMORING FOR.
BUT, YOU KNOW, THE ISSUE HERE,
AND WE HAVE SEEN THIS BEFORE,
LIKE IF YOU THINK BACK TO THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION, WHEN
TRUMP HAD A SIMILAR STRUGGLE TO
GET REALLY SERIOUS, SEASONED,
WELL RESPECTED LAWYERS ON HIS
TEAM, YOU KNOW, HE DOESN'T
ALWAYS TAKE ADVICE, HE DOESN'T
ALWAYS PAY THE BILL, AND HE'S
VERY CONTROVERSIAL.
A LOT OF FIRMS AND A LOT OF
LAWYERS DON'T WANT THE HEADACHES
THAT WOULD GO ALONG WITH
REPRESENTING HIM.
YOU KNOW, WE HEARD FROM ONE
LAWYER, A STORY ABOUT HOW, YOU
KNOW, THEY WENT TO THE OVAL
OFFICE FOR SOMETHING AND TOLD
HIM NOT TO TWEET AND BY THE TIME
THEY GOT TO THE WHITE HOUSE
DRIVEWAY AND CHECKED THEIR
PHONES, THERE WAS A TWEET.
>> ISAAC ARNSDORF, THANK YOU FOR
BEING WITH US AND SHARING YOUR
REPORTING.